I've never had a relationship
thats lasted very long
Even now, that I've found
my soulmate
It's taken work to
keep that connection solid
That's where Leslie and I are
right now
Gotta a lot of work to do
You know when you'll be back
I don't know, later
Gotta go
Love You, Baby
>> WE HAD A LITTLE WEDDING THING
WITH EVERYONE WHICH WAS AMAZING.
>> IT'S OFFICIAL!
WE'RE MARRIED!
>> I REMEMBER WHEN MY PARENTS
CAME INTO MY ROOM WHEN I WAS 9.
THEY TOLD ME THEY WERE GETTING A
DIVORCE.
AND I DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN
TO ME AND LESLIE.
I DEFINITELY DON'T THAPT TO
HAPPEN TO OUR KIDS.
LITTLE LAUREN.
>> I DON'T SEE WHAT THE BIG DEAL
IS.
I LOVE MY FAMILY, OKAY?
I'M JUST BUSY.
THE SHOW, MOVIES, INTERVIEWS,
STAND UP.
IT'S A LOT.
AND KYLE, HE'S NOT BUSY.
HE'S BARELY ON THE SHOW AND WHAT
HAS HE DONE IN THE LAST YEAR?
COME ON, MAN.
>> LET ME KNOW IF YOU NEED ME.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE COME UP TO ME
AND SAY WERE YOU NEIGHBORS TOO?
I'M LIKE YES.
AWESOME.
>> CAN WE TALK?
>> I AM REHEARSING.
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU COME HOME LAST
NIGHT?
>> I WAS AT THE OFFICE.
>> WITH COLIN.
>> YES, BUT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
LIKE THAT.
>> WE NEED TO GET HELP.
>> I'LL, I'M NOT HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
>> TOMORROW IS HIS RECITAL AND
YOU PROMISED YOU WOULDN'T MISS
IT.
>> I KNOW.
I WILL BE THERE.
>> KYLE HAS BEEN TRYING TO SEE
SOMEONE TO TALK ABOUT OUR
PROBLEMS.
I DON'T NEED SOMEONE TELLING ME
HOW TO LIVE MY LIFE.
>> I WILL START.
I LOVE HER.
IT'S AN EMOTIONAL EXPERIENCE FOR
ME AND I CRY.
>> AND I FEEL THAT MAKES HIM A
LITTLE BITCH.
>> I JUST WANT TO MEMORIZE MY
LINES.
>> I HAVE TO WORK LATE.
SEE YOU LATER.
>> BYE, LESLIE.
WELL, TONIGHT IS THE BIG
RECITAL.
I'M ACTUALLY PRETTY NERVOUS, BUT
LITTLE LAUREN WILL BE GREAT.
I'M A PROUD DAD.
>> OH, MY GOD.
DID WE MISS IT?
>> I'M SO SORRY.
WE WERE WORKING ON A SCRIPT AND
GOT CARRIED AWAY.
IT'S MY FAULT.
>> I DON'T USUALLY SUPPORT CAST
MEMBERS SHOOTING EACH OTHER, BUT
COLIN CAN BE ANNOYING.
>> WELL, IT'S BEEN A PRETTY
CRAZY WEEK.
COLIN ENDED UP SURVIVING WHICH
IS AWESOME.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE SURVIVED?
OUR LOVE.
>> WE ARE HAVING ANOTHER BABY!
WE WILL NAME HIM WEEKEND UPDATE.